yeah welcome to this video playing Habba
Habba Habba Habba he doesn't have
doesn't have a like in them so yeah
maybe maybe try this there once I think
actually after d4 d5 this London is a
relatively good opening I mean I don't
think that it is much worse than the
Queen's Gambit in terms of playing for
an edge of course I mean it's not worse
than any any kind so let's see if we
transpose is sending me a message that I
uploaded several of our games I don't
really remember playing himself okay so
so let's see normally Queen b6 is play T
and after c5 why does an excellent shape
maybe he's trying to avoid that
with Quincy aid it's asking me if I'm
doing commentary yep I do
but he says I'm losing so badly again I
don't know
yeah it's not such a great position but
nothing really dramatic happened yet
yeah I prefer Quincy am queen bee 65 is
really a bit one-sided okay just develop
nanite h5s er sometimes but okay let's
let's maybe try to irritate with CD 5 at
night b5 Luke is not bad on c1 anyway
I don't think I'm threatening much
really I mean cd5 he can do 95 and so
maybe just Bishop e7
yeah but he's spending lots of time here
yeah it's not very comfortable yeah so
yeah taking a cab to take with the night
all the charm just just develop and then
castles
the position is certainly comfortable
but it's not easy to to see a direct way
forward because it's simply simply
rather closed yeah
should I please see five c5 and Queen a
for this is a a way to to play that
intended before but on awesome other
square Queen a4 has the idea to play
after b6 to play a bishop a6 but Queen a
for him I play e5 and it's not clear
that this helped me hmm yeah but back to
Devon I don't know maybe c5 wasn't so
great but I can't do that if he plays a
five I return ok it's not a bhakti bear
not a big deal you came to us going for
something entirely different
ok then I'll play before me before b5
yeah I think he must play a six now
allowing before b5 is simply not
possible unless there's some technical
stuff but I don't see it
yeah a six is the animals
hmm very very drastic solution if I take
a baby right yeah interesting he wants
to take off before
hmmm how to play this that's very
interesting if I drop back he's going to
play a five
Queen a5 should be 8
and there's also the smooth
it's not it's not CLE at all
let's check this to capture again it
takes B it takes between b3 at service
its playable for black yeah but maybe I
need to do it anyway
this is strange b5 was an interesting
move I didn't consider this at all and
it looks crazy at first at least in my
book I came yeah now a B I guess Knight
takes I can just go back to b3 and
better Queen here takes before so I need
to drop back yeah this one
how weird is that
yeah I really don't understand what what
went wrong here what do we at game what
to be five maybe I should second be five
or something they can just take a - no
I'm disappointed yeah this is really
strange
join 496 I don't really understand what
went wrong damn what a strange game
sometimes
993 yeah but it's it's a crap position
anyway no matter what I do it's opponent
it's just much better coordinated okay
maybe yeah I can I can fight like that
it's got got opposite colored bishops
check
I'm warning tech check checkmate
yeah yeah yeah what the correct game I
don't understand what happened here what
it's just it's just a much better
position for a while and then be five
over two mp5s versus leading to two
natural black but yeah the computer
merely gives black an edge off to b5
yeah this is weird how is this possible
I mean obviously I must have done
something wrong but to what exactly it's
really it's really cute this this
unstable rook on b3 s is really the
issue let's say I would take let's say I
take yeah and then play before then it's
it's it's it's a different different
story
yeah I can still play it
I probably need to go here and get this
bishop first
yes um somewhere along these lines sir
is the solution to all this but that b5
is leading to two black advantageous is
quite quite amazing yeah maybe I should
but I cannot really do that I thought
let's say he I and and and play here but
it cannot do that he takes replaced okay
one it's just it's just amazing how
quickly this goes downhill yeah and this
is terrible we saw that in the game but
what what to do maybe I should have
taken I mean it's not it's not working
at all
but even this this means yeah it's not
even a practical tribe yeah then I'm
just I'm just busted after b5 in a way
Wow
Wow what can I say
yeah after the Sun I'm just in terrible
shape and F know I have no alternative
what should I do is piss flattening c4
with the positional win let's say
castles for example here something like
that it's just winning for blanket just
one idea and the whole structure is just
just a mess so I need to take and then
yeah I'm just I'm just done here yeah
okay and at the end I didn't I don't
need to another made and this is
actually a slight chance to fight but
there was I admit I was so shocked
irritated by all this check check yeah
okay but it's this doesn't help but I
was so irritated by the game that didn't
I didn't really look so closely amazing
alright thanks for watching